while she goes from Mike in Colorado
Dave I'm looking to make a Christmas
purchase for my wife on some jewelry we
shop together to find her the right gift
and the store is offering an option to
save some money by opening a credit card
with their store we don't intend to keep
this card but we could save a few
hundred dollars with this purchase or
the potential downfalls or things we
should be aware of before opening this
line of credit I would tell that store
that if they do not give me the discount
without opening the credit card that I
will buy a piece of jewelry somewhere
else
get the manager in front of you and go
you have got to be kidding me you've got
to be kidding me you're gonna hold me
hostage to give me a discount no you're
not you're gonna give me a discount or
I'm gonna walk no I'm not opening a
credit card to get a discount ever if
you play with snakes you will be bitten
you open that card up somebody steals
your identity and all of a sudden that
has a big balance on it and now you're
gonna spend the next two years screwing
around with this trying to get your
identity theft mess straightened out
that you would have never had if you
didn't try to screw around with some
store credit card offer where you got a
discount listen these companies these
retailers make more on credit card
interest than they do on the sale of the
stuff all of them do Victoria's Secret
makes much more on their store card than
they do on their undies they are not in
the underwear business they're in the
credit business with some underwear out
front this jewelry store is not in the
jewelry store business they're in the
credit business with some stuff out
front to get you into this deal don't
fall for it don't play their game well
they want to sell me anything then tell
them to stick it and go buy somewhere
else I'm not doing business with
somebody that treats me that way that
you're gonna blackmail me into getting
your stupid store card
don't offer me a discount if I sign up
for your cart because then I'm gonna
demand the discount anyway I'm not gonna
be abused by you retailers I'm your
freakin customer besides that I'm all
jewelry store is not the best place to
buy that probably anyway jewelry is the
most markup on it about anything out
there other than furniture so it's a
good idea to think about maybe buying
that somewhere else to start with but
you can give them one shot if you want
give me the discount anyway no I'm not
taking out a credit card no I'm not
putting my family at risk for a little
bit of a discount on something you
should have given me a discount on to
start with guys when you into Best Buy
they make more on extended warranties
and on credit than they do on the sale
of the merchandise Best Buy actually is
a good buy they don't have a lot of
margin in their flat-screen TVs there's
no huge markup they're not big big you
notice they don't have hundreds and
hundreds of dollars on a thousand dollar
item it's just a few dollars that's why
they when you go up to checkout at Best
Buy I mean if you're buying a pencil
they'll put an extended warranty on it
and finance it for you
because they want you to be in debt to
them and to buy their extended
warranties is where they make all their
money
translation you shouldn't do either one